Ich höre nicht.
Okay, gutmorgen, ich heiße Sedat Ota.
Ich bin auch der Station Al-Dastetik.
Ich möchte das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Natürlich, gerne.
Okay, wunderbar.
Dann können wir mit persönlicher Tag und wir gehen da zum Beginn.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Klein.
Sabine Klein.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Können Sie Ihre Nachname bitte langsam bestabieren?
K-L-E-I-N.
Okay.
Frau Klein, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
Und wann gehen Sie in die Geborene?
Am 12. April 1979.
Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m groß.
Und Frau Klein, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 82 Kilogramm.
Können Sie bitte wieder?
82 Kilogramm.
80.
Okay, können Sie mir bitte sagen, wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt?
Es ist der Herr Schmidt.
Okay, Frau Klein, was für Sie zu uns, was für welche Werden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit nun ungefähr anderthalb Wochen Schmerzen im Oberbau.
Und die kriege ich einfach nicht los.
Und was meint ihr mit Oberbau?
Ganzer Oberbau oder rechter oder linken Seite?
Wo genau haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Ja, wir sind also mittig bis rechts.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben, wenn Sie drückend brennend wellen vor mich?
Das ist drückend, aber auch manchmal plötzlich wellend für mich.
Und auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei es für sehr starke Schmerzen steht.
Wie starke sind die Schmerzen?
Ungefähr so 5 bis 6.
Und schreien die Schmerzen aus?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Aber ich habe auch Rückenschmerzen.
Ich weiß, ob das ganz vom Rücken kommt, eventuell.
Manchmal glaube ich, dass die Wandscheibe wieder Probleme macht.
Würden Sie sagen, dass die Schmerzen Rink für mich oder Gürtel für mich?
Nein, nicht Gürtel für mich, aber die sind ja so wellend für mich.
Im Oberbau, aber auch im Rücken.
Seit 1 Wurfe, wie gesagt.
Wenn die Schmerzen lange lang an die Schmerzen kommen?
Die sind eigentlich immer da, aber manchmal werden sie stärker.
Das dauert schon mehrere Minuten.
Okay, ich denke.
Haben Sie diese Schmerzen schon einmal gehabt?
Nein, noch nie.
Ich habe eigentlich sehr selten Schmerzen, außer meine bekannten Bandscheidenproblematik.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, das ist plötzlich auch getretende Schmerzen.
Ich habe ja mehr über 1-2 Wochen hingegangen.
Und Frau Klein, gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen verbessert oder verschlimmert?
Eine Körperhaltung, Essen, Bewegen?
Nein, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass nach dem Essen schlimmer wird.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es nach dem Essen schlimmer wird.
Mit dem Essen, okay.
Haben Sie eine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Ja, ich nehme jeden Tag E-Profen ein, zweimal am Tag.
Und hilft das?
Ja, das hilft.
Das hilft ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch andere Beglachtsbechwerden?
Zum Beispiel Übelkeit, Müdigkeit, Erbrechen?
Ja, Übelkeit habe ich.
Erbrochen habe ich noch nicht, aber Übelkeit habe ich schon.
Und ich habe auch so eine Völlegefühl habe ich.
Ich muss sehr oft aufstoßen.
Haben Sie auch eine saure Geschmack im Mund?
Nein.
Haben Sie auch Sortbrennen?
Selten.
Frau Klein, leiden Sie unter voller Gefühl oder fühlen Sie sich aufgebildet?
Ja, ja, habe ich ja gesagt, voller Gefühl.
Haben Sie das Gefühl, manchmal, dass Sie so teuletten müssen, aber da kommt eigentlich nichts?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ist Ihnen Husten aufgefallen?
Husten?
Ja.
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Nein.
Frau Klein, ist Ihnen Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Herzstoffen bemerkt?
Okay.
Aber haben Sie Feberstufos oder nach Schweiß?
Nein, das habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit umgeholt ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe leider ein bisschen zugenommen.
Wie viel und in welchem Zeit war?
Ich habe jetzt ein, zwei Kilo zugenommen in den letzten paar Tagen.
Und wie ist Ihr Appatit?
Eigentlich ganz gut.
Kein Problem.
Frau Klein, haben Sie Veränderungen oder Probleme mit Ihrer Sturrgang oder beim Wasserlassenbemmen?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Besuchung ist regelmäßig Ihr Frauenast?
Ja, ich war jetzt zuletzt vor einem Jahr da.
Und wie ist es, wenn Sie sich an die Sturz gestorben haben?
Und wann hatten Sie die letzte Periode?
Das kommt jetzt die Tage.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Leider nicht.
Frau Klein, leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine damit Blutzuckerkrankheit, Blutdruckdruck.
Ich habe einen beginnenden Blutdruck, sagte mein Hausarzt mir.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente dagegen?
Nein, er sagt, ich solle abnehmen, aber ich habe leider das Gegenteil gemacht.
Gibt es auch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Super.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich habe in meiner Kindheit die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Okay.
Frau Klein, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder gelegentlich mit.
Ibu Profin, nehme ich ab und zu ein.
Ich habe auch sehr auf Kopfschmerzen.
Deswegen habe ich immer Ibu Profin da.
Sind Sie völlig geimpft?
Bitte?
Gegen Kinderkrankheiten, gegen Corona und so?
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagt ja.
Ich habe mich auch sehr geimpft.
Ich habe sehr geimpft.
Ich habe meine Kinderkrankheiten gegen Corona und so.
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagt ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit in das Ausland eine Reise gemacht?
Ich war zuletzt im Winter in Holland.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Haustau.
Und wie ausstatt sich diese Haustau Allergie?
Niesen und Juckreis.
Juckreis, ok.
Rachen Sie?
Ich bin nicht drauf.
Trägen Sie Alkohol?
Zeltel.
Nur am Wochenende.
Ok.
Also, wir können sagen, 2 Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Ist das nur der Vorteil?
Ja, ja.
Und das ist eine routine Frage. Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder andere Substanz?
Nein.
Frau Krain, ist Ihre Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Noch mal, bitte.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Zum Beispiel Brustverkrankheit, Bruttochdruck, Magen, Herz oder Lebererkrankungen.
Ja, also es gibt Zucker in der Familie bei uns.
Meine beiden Eltern haben beide Zucker.
Ist das Alterszucker?
Was bedeutet Alterszucker?
Bitte.
Was meinen Sie mit Alterszucker?
Ich meine, nachdem Sie 40 oder 50 Jahren sind, sind Sie eine Erwassene.
Oder sind Sie mit dieser Krankheit geboren?
Nein, Sie haben das später bekommen erst.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die leben noch, ja.
Und sonst, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind recht fit, muss man sagen.
Also, die gehen regelmäßig spazieren, sie sind noch so fit.
Wunderbar.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Und Frau Klein, Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden, tut mir leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter.
Und ich hoffe, dass sie gesund ist?
Ja, ich liebe Ihren Vater.
Sie ist gesund.
Was sind Sie von Bürokratie?
Ich arbeite im Büro als Bürokratie.
Gibt es viel Stress im Arbeitsplatz oder im Privatleben?
Immer, wir haben immer Stress.
Jeder von uns hat Stress.
Ich möchte über Kopfschmerzen ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ist Ihre Kopfschmerzen nur einseitig?
Oder woher haben Sie diese Kopfschmerzen?
Meine Kopfschmerzen sind eher so einseitig, richtig.
Meistens auf der linken Seite.
Aber nicht immer.
Wechseln Sie manchmal die Seite oder immer an der linken Seite.
Oft links.
Haben Sie Probleme mit den Augen?
Mit den Augen?
Tragen Sie Brille?
Ich trage Kontaktinsen.
Träten Ihre Kopfschmerzen plötzlich oder gibt es vorher Anzeigen?
Zum Beispiel Billetze im Gesicht oder in den Fingern oder auf der Papariz?
Wie treten Sie plötzlich auf?
Ich bin heute hier wegen meinen Bauchschmerzen.
Was wissen Sie?
Haben Sie Licht- oder Lärmempfindigkeit?
Leiden Sie unter Licht- oder Lärmempfindigkeit?
Nein.
Sind Sie unmetziger geworden?
Wegen den Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, wegen dieser Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe aktuell keine Kopfschmerzen.
Aber Bauchschmerzen.
Das waren meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Was glauben Sie?
Im Moment ist es eine Diagnose für Stellen.
Wir brauchen körperliche Untersuchungen,
Blutabnehmen und Darstellungsmethode.
Dann werde ich Ihre Enfalle mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Danach werde ich mich bei Ihnen melden.
Okay, ich stelle.
Sie können im Wartesum erwarten.
Wie werden Sie anrufen?
Danke.
Haben Sie einen Kollegen oder einen Kollegen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Wir sind der Schutulfarbe oder Urinfarbe.
Oder haben Sie Veränderungen?
Nein, das ist alles normal.
Meine zweite Frage ist,
ob Sie gerne Fleisch oder Fettreihendes gewichen?
Ja, schon, aber ich esse das nicht immer.
Ich esse das schon gerne.
Das heißt nicht, dass ich es gar essen kann.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Haben Sie sich übergeben?
Sie haben schon Übelkeit?
Nein, ich habe nicht übergeben.
Aber ich habe keine Erbrechungen.
Nein.
Okay.
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen oder getrunken?
Eigentlich nicht, immer das, was ich gleich was immer mache.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine geltliche Verfahrung Ihrer Haut oder Augen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie die Urinfarbe verändert?
Wurde gerade gestellt die Frage.
Haben Sie die Schmerzen in der Läufe der Zeit verändert?
Nein, im Läufe der Zeit verändert.
Die Schmerzen, ob Sie sich verändert haben?
Nein, die sind eigentlich gleich.
Die kommen und gehen, werden manchmal stärker, manchmal weniger.
Die Kollegen und die werden für mich.
Zwei Fragen, Kollegen, noch andere Fragen.
Okay.
Und gestellte Fragen müssen wir nicht wieder stellen.
Wiederholen.
Ja, noch eine Frage bitte.
Ist Galun Citein Leiden bei Ihnen oder bei Ihrer Familie bekannt?
Nein.
Haben Sie die Brustschmerzen oder einen Engelfür in der Brust?
Eigentlich nicht.
Entschuldigung, wurden Sie schon einmal morgen spiegeln durchgeführt?
Noch nie.
Okay, danke schön.
Eine gute Frage.
Ich werde Ihre Fragen stellen.
Können wir als Alsals-Gespräch anfangen?
Okay.
Herr Oberarzt, wir haben eine neue Patientin, Frau Klein,
mit einer Klinik, die über Sie berichten.
Aber Sie sind seitdem.
Sehr schön, ja.
Okay.
Frau Klein ist eine 45-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,68 m groß und 89 kg.
Sie bestellte sich mit über ein Wochen bestehenden oberbauer Schmerzen,
epigastischer Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzinterstate ist 5 bis 6 von 10 auf eine Schmerzskala.
Diese sind Wellenförmige und in den Rücken strahlende Schmerzen.
Schmerzen verschlimmet sich nach dem Essen.
Über Profen, ein Name, verbesserte Schmerzen.
Desweiteren klagte sie über Nasch.
Immer was?
Und Rupsen, öfter aufstoßen.
Er hat keine Husten.
Und außerdem klagte sie, dass sie sich aufgewählt fühlen.
Und letzte Winter, Sie sind völlig geirnst.
Letzte Winter war sie in Holland.
Als Vorerkrankungen, zur Stattna arteriale Fypertonie.
Aber er nimmt keine Medikamente dagegen noch nicht.
Im Kindheit hat sie Tonselektomie.
Und außerdem klagte sie über Koffschmerzen.
Linker Seite Koffschmerzen.
Hat das weggenommen?
Und allergien, sie hat Haustapalergie ist bekannt.
Ausseßlich als Jucken, Pruritus.
Noxen, Nikotinabusus wurde verneint.
Alkoholkonsum mit 2 Gläserweinpobohe beacht.
Drogenkonsum verneint.
Sie ist geschädend, hat ein Tochter, arbeitet im Büro.
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben Fischtes in ihrer täglichen Leben.
In ihrer Familie.
Beide Eltern hat Diabetes meleutus Typ 2.
Sonst, sie sind gesund und sie hat eine Schwester.
Sie ist auch gesund.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Als Felser hat nur sie, der ist der pflüchste Sie.
Machen sie oder rückfluss.
Warum denken sie das?
Es gibt Oberbauchschmerzen.
Sie trinkt Wein.
Hat sie auch rechtseitige Oberbauchschmerzen?
Bitte.
Herzseitig.
Rechtsseitig, rechtseitige Oberbauchschmerzen?
Sie haben gesagt, auch strahlen einem rechte Seite.
Deshalb können wir sagen, die Französer hat auch nur Schkallenstein
oder Scholelithiasis oder Scholesuskitis auch möglich.
Breten die Beschwerden nach dem Essen auf?
Besonders postprandes Schmerzen.
Nach dem Essen fühlen sie sich schlechter.
Hat sie Sod brennen?
Bitte.
Nicht auf, aber sie haben gesagt, manchmal habe ich Sod brennen.
Hat sie Sod brennen nachts mehr oder morgens mehr?
Hab ich diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Ich musste fragen.
Und strahlen die Schmerzen noch irgendwo aus?
Oder hat sie nur Oberbauchschmerzen und rechtseitige Schmerzen?
Schmerzstrahlen im Rücken.
Was muss man noch als Differenzialdiagnose mit bedenken?
Im Rücken fallen die Bauchschmerzen,
sollen wir Pankratitis denken, Pankratitis denken
und Kulutabnehmen, Pankratiaswerte kontrollieren,
Instruktionsparameter kontrollieren,
Tomografie vielleicht oder Abdomenssonne können wir auch.
Was machen Sie jetzt mit den Patienten?
Nicht alles auf einmal sagen.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Zuerst mache ich körperliche Untersuchungen.
Zum Differenzialdiagnostik kann ich einfach
sehen diese Hartfad-Veränderungen,
diese gelbliche oder grünliche Verfärbung beim Appendiaspankratitis
um die Nabel um anderen Flanken.
Oder auch körperliche Untersuchungen beim Durchschmerzen
oder Abwehrspannung.
Wir können die körperlichen Untersuchungen zwischen
gastro-sophagellen Flugserkrankungen
und Gallenstein unterscheiden.
Wir können palpieren, wenn es Gallenstein gibt,
er würde Rückschmerzen oder Rückloschmerzen.
Wie nennt man das?
Wie nennt man diese Zeich?
Wir fragen den Patienten tief einatmen
und wenn wir unser Hengen wegziehen,
dann wird der Patient viel schmerz.
Aber die Name ist mehr entfalt.
Murphie Zeichen.
Sie nehmen Blut auf, Sie untersuchen ihn.
Was machen Sie noch?
In der Ambulanz?
Wir nehmen Blut.
Wir können Bauchutraschein machen.
Es gibt Gallenstein, wir können das sehen.
Ich denke nicht, aber wir können ausschließen.
Willst du damit zu tun?
Ja, würde ich auch ausschließen.
Wir können auch freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch feststellen.
Was machen wir mit den Patienten jetzt?
Wir müssen hier bleiben.
Nach dem Diagnosieren können wir darüber sprechen.
Aber im Moment soll sie hier bleiben.
Wann können Sie hier bleiben?
Wenn er Gastroenterfegerlebstkrankheit hat,
müssen Sie nicht im Krankenhaus,
sondern im Krankenhaus.
Wenn er eine Diagnose hat,
müssen Sie nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Glauben Sie immer noch,
dass die Patientin eine gastro-syphagiale Flugserkrankung hat?
Es könnte auch Kohlestätik oder Kohlestätik sein.
Wenn er sie hat,
dann könnte er nicht gehen.
Zuerst sollen wir stationäre Aufnehmen,
nachdem wir Diagnosieren.
Wir brauchen eine chirurgische Konzil.
Sie brauchen nicht immer chirurgische Konzil.
Wann lassen Sie die Patientin im Krankenhaus
und wann sollen sie nach Hause?
Sagen Sie mal, sie hat eine schole Zystole Thiasis.
Die Blutwerte sind gut,
CRP ist normal.
Im Ultraschall haben Sie keine Entzündung festgestellt.
Muss die Patientin im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Nein, dann empfehlen wir regelmäßige Kontrolle.
Wenn es eine plötzliche Exer-Serbation gibt,
können wir wieder darüber sprechen.
Wann bleibt sie im Krankenhaus,
wenn sie eine Entzündung hat?
Wenn Sie merken, dass die Gallenblase entzündet ist,
eine Abszess vorliegt,
eventuell eine Gallenblase,
dann muss man ein chirurgisches Konzil erstellen.
Es kann sein, dass sie Antibiotikum braucht.
Was empfehlen Sie der Patientin?
Was wir empfehlen,
Lebenszeitveränderung,
Sportreiben und Ernährungsberatung
ist auch wichtig,
weil er hat eine Ernehmung.
Wir haben eine Ernehmung,
eine Ernährungsberatung ist auch wichtig,
weil er hat, wenn sie Gallensteine hat,
empfehlen wir regelmäßige Kontrolle.
Wir müssen beim Haus oder im Krankenhaus kommen.
Im Krankenhaus nicht, aber Haus muss kontrollieren.
Aber jetzt hat die Patientin
das erste Mal diese Beschwerden.
Er hat das noch nie vorher gehabt.
Wenn das immer wieder auftritt,
jedes Jahr oder alle drei Monate,
diese Beschwerden, was empfehlen Sie der Patientin?
Immer wieder, jedes Jahr.
Sie könnte operiert werden,
aber...
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Wenn Sie möchten, das ist möglich.
Was macht man da?
Schon ist es tec-tomy.
Komplett aus die Gallen, ne?
Ja, Gallenblase.
Können Sie sie wieder beteiligen?
Nehmt man die Gallenblase weg?
Gallenblase.
Nicht nur Gallenblase.
Was wäre denn, wenn die Patientin
die Schuhe hätte, äkterisch wäre?
Welchen Medaillen-Diagnose hätten Sie dann?
Wenn ich die Hose hatte,
dann würde ich das in der Gallenwerke
für die Fragen nach
Zahndunge mit dem Stuhlgang
oder mit Urin, zum Beispiel
dunkler Urin oder helle Stuhlgang.
Was würden Sie dann machen?
Dann mache ich Ultraschall.
Ich muss sehen, wie ich das stelle.
Ich muss die Plut abnehmen
und diese Entsündungsparameter kontrollieren.
Wenn wir brauchen, können wir auch
MRI oder Tomographie machen.
Jetzt habt ihr erhöhte Scholas-Tase-Parameter, sagen wir mal, ne?
Sie habt erhöhte Scholas-Tase-Parameter.
Da ist ein Stein im Gallengang.
Wenn eine Entsündung in Gallen steckt,
dann sollen wir ...
Ich nehme stationäre und Nahrungskarrens.
Natürlich gebe ich Plüsk- und Elektrolytien.
Was macht man dann?
Stationäre Aufnahmen.
Richtig, das stimmt. Aber was macht
im Verlauf, was passiert dann?
Was ist die Therapie eines ...
einer Schollodoholitiersis?
Wie heißt diese Operation?
Das ist keine Operation.
Als Therapie ...
Wie bekommt man diesen Stein weg?
Ich ...
wir können durch die Operation wegmachen,
aber mit Medikamente?
Nein.
Mit einer ERCP.
Ja, endoscopic retrograde,
mit dem Pyrangeliopank.
Ich dachte auch, das ist eine Operation.
Keine richtige Operation.
Man muss nichts schneiden.
Man nennt nur den Stein daraus. Endoscopic.
Ja.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Wir sagen, Diagnose ist Schollodoholitiersis.
Schollodoholitiersis, okay.
Aber ein Kollege noch andere Fragen?
Alles ist klar. Ganz einfach Abfall.
Ja.
Ich habe es gesagt.
Ich möchte etwas fragen, Muro.
Wir haben gesagt,